very good well it's nice to have you
here i don't know if you remember me
but i study the cosmic microwave
background radiation
and today we're going to talk a lot
about the early history
of cosmology in particular giant's work
and his books i have two of his books
here which i referenced in my book
losing the nobel prize this one current
issues in cosmology
and this one uh facts and speculations
in cosmology and the first thing i want
to
begin with is if giant if you can
explain
how you got how you first met jeffrey
burbidge my late colleague at uc san
diego
how did you first meet jeff burbidge
how you met jeffrey burbeach so
what happened was i had been a student
of fred oil
in cambridge and i
used to hear about him from fred
and then when one day
he turned up in cambridge he both he and
margaret
and there was a great deal of excitement
as if some heroes have come you know
with their names
their name had preceded them so
a number of us students were waiting to
talk
to him and he came and then
we had a informal
talk and then he disappeared
then i saw him only when i went to san
diego
that was a little later
and how did you meet fred hoyle
oh how did i meet fred he was your
advisor
after i finished my
what they called the tripos examination
which is
the final degree examination before
entering as a research student then
i did fairly well so i
i was given the first choice of
to whom i could go
for first preference so i
went to fred and fred was
told that there will be three people
coming one after the other
so he gave me 10 o'clock time
the second in the morning before the
second one
came back to one hour later and the
third one another hour later
so that was like
john faulkner was one of them
and when he came to
when i came to see him i found that he
was very informal
and he mentioned
a few topics for research
whatever i would like to pick up
and i said they're fine but
why don't you give me steady state
theory
to work on so he said
that that there are certainly many
interesting problems in steady state
theory
but i do not want to keep
my student in a controversial position
so i want to give him a topic which is
relatively straightforward that is why
he was not giving this so i okay
said okay i took one of the other
problems he had given and it so happened
that within a few months i solved it
so it could not last me for three years
you know for graduate things so
uh and in the meantime
uh ryan martin royal came up with his
source counts and
fred was in a way challenged
that the source count was inconsistent
with his
cosmology so he asked me
to come and work with him to see whether
we can
salvage the cosmology
by some trick
it was so we said we let us look at
it in the following way and we
tried a new method and it seemed to work
so he said you go and
you will talk on this at the royal
astronomical society
so i said why should i talk to you you
are the leader
so he said no but at that day i am
i am supposed to lecture somewhere else
so the somebody has to reply
to ryle so i want you to do it
so i was a bit scared to take part in a
controversy
as a raw research student
so finally uh this did happen i
managed to convince the audience that
there was a case
and therefore the
purpose was served and then
i as you see instead of
being avoiding controversial topic i
was put right into in the midst of it
this was the beginning of the
quasi-steady-state cosmology or had he
already started that campaign
was this the beginning of quasi-steady
state
i don't think so oh the
quasi-steady-state
theory came much later this was
when barbies and
oil and i the three of us
we had got a number of times together
uh in the royal greenish observatory in
the uk
and in ucsd so finally
we had suggested a
cosmology which is endless
that means it has no beginning no end
and also it had no singularity
so it was free from space-time
singularity
and it produced the
microwave background without any
difficulty which steady-state theory had
not been able to do
so this causes steady state theory
has had several papers on it
in astrophysical journal astronomy
astrophysics
and so on and we feel that
that cosmology needs to be
examined under whatever latest
observations are
and that model in quasi-steady state
cosmology
featured a new approach that wasn't
exactly
static it was evolving very slowly
via the presence of a new creation field
a field that you guys called the sea
field whose idea was the sea
field whose idea was
sea field the idea of causing steady
state
well the c field itself the actual
creation
in particular c field but then okay
c field used in quasi steady state
c let us see okay this is the c
field was proposed for steady state
theory
and we got at that time a very simple
solution
now when causing steady state was to be
considered
we wanted to put in more
kind of what you call parameters so
it became necessary to use the same c
field formulation but with take a more
general
solution and that is what we did in
qssc
and that could account for the expansion
and sorry and it was an idea which
one cannot really uh identify as the who
was the
one among the three we were all involved
in
throwing the ideas around discussing
right now you had earlier worked
on what was known as the hoyle narlikar
theory of gravity was that coil
narlikar was the purpose of that to
provide a foundation
for the qss for the quasi-steady-state
cosmology
or was it independent of cosmology
at all
your gravitation theory with fred
was it connected with quasi steady state
somehow
our gravitational theory was
in fact the motivator
for for quasi quasi-steady-state
cosmology
so when i said that we wanted to
generalize the earlier c
field idea that c field idea was
generalized
creation field idea was generalized
by taking some ideas out of
our gravitational theory
so it's a kind of cross between these
two
um these two models
and hoyle uh of course is very famous
because he came up uh in with many
things
including the oil resonance and other
properties
but he's perhaps most famous for making
the name
big bang uh do you think that he
intended it to stick for 70 years and
more
or do you think he thought it would go
away as a joke more
more than anything else how did he get
the idea
name big bang and did he expect the name
to stay or be gone well
well fred always addressed it as the big
bang
he didn't care who else
or got it or used the same world or not
but as you probably know the sky and
telescope magazine
had run a kind of competition
for an alternative name and they came
back saying
big bang is the best
yes i remember at that time was saying
to me
that they should have given him the
price for
for the best name
was he a person of good humor was he
lighthearted or was he
more serious
was he light-hearted more humored or
more serious
more what humor did he have a sense of
humor
or was he more serious fred had say
certain ideas in which he would
be triggered off into
series of laughters if he had thought of
something happening there
but there were limited topics in which
he would be
humorous he otherwise he was more
kind of serious kind
and they um
the notion of the of the going back to
quasi-steady state cosmology
the sea field some uh claims have said
that
it was related to the
later discovery of dark energy how did
you react
when teams announced in the late 1990s
the discovery of an accelerated
expansion
of the universe connection with dark
energy what do you
think well is when you take the
quasi-steady-state
cosmology then the need for
dark matter or dark energy
became different in the following
compared to big bang for the following
reason for example
in the big bang cosmology
if you take the early universe when the
deuterium was formed so at that time
how much deuterium you can make depends
on what is the maximum
[Music]
density of baryonic matter
if the baryonic matter exceeded a
certain
limit no no the deuterium will be formed
so big bang needed to
uh exceed that density but i did not
want it to be
baryonic so they said the excess must be
an
ultra this what you call them
without that it is a dark
matter a non-baryonic matter
that is why that came into play in qssc
the dark
darkness is there but that is no
ordinary matter
it is not the strange kind of
non-baryonic dark matter
that is a main difference
and the acceleration there was
acceleration
in the qssc as well i wonder
if um if you're familiar with ideas
now by people like alan guth certainly
you know about inflation
you've spoken about that what challenge
do you think
is the most significant challenge to the
big bang
and then i'm gonna ask you what is the
most significant challenge to the
quasi-steady state cosmology but first
let's start with the
standard cosmological model that
so-called big bang
cosmology what is the biggest flaw
in your opinion of the big bang and then
i'll ask you about the
quasi-steady state what is
the biggest flaw or the problem
before big bang biggest flaw
and something that you don't agree with
flaw
what is the biggest defect of looking
back
microwave background has been the main
problem which
on which big bang people have
tried to argue
that the
[Music]
non-big bank cosmologies like
qssc or steady state old study state
they were not valid because they could
not explain
microwave background now our answer to
that is that the
explanation of microwave background in
usac is quite different and it comes
from
previous generations of stars with
starlight getting into
uh thermalization process
and it ends up as microwave radiation
so the advantage with our model
compared to the big bang is that
in the big bang theory they don't know
what is the ultimate temperature today
is
it turned out to be 2.7 but
why 2.7 why not three or two five or ten
that question used to say that
[Music]
our gamma
he used to give different answers each
time he was asked
what is the temperature so he
said 5 degrees then 10 degrees
15 degrees so he the burmese was saying
that
they don't have any theory whereas in
our case
if we know how much starlight is around
from we can do a calculation and show
that
the temperature is about 2.8
so we are in a sense better than
the standard cosmology but people have
not
taken it very seriously
yeah it is true that the fluctuation
of let me just repeat your question
because i think he has answered it in a
different way
yes his first question was
what is the most important defect
of big bang do you think this is the
most
important defect problem or flaw
with big bang or is there any other
see what we feel is that
both these accelerating universe idea
and microwave background these are
kind of put in by hand afterwards and
this people actually don't
know why the acceleration is so much and
so forth
whereas in alternative cosmology in our
qsac as
barbies and i had shown in one paper
which we have shown that it is possible
to explain the
redshift magnitude relation for
distant supernovae
emitters stars galaxies
and that has been
explained in our theory by saying that
there is a
background of intergalactic dust
which thermalizes and absorbs which
is equivalent to a
universe which is apparently
accelerating
so our idea is that there is an
alternative way
and the big bang method is not very good
uh it has been put in by hand
right so that's interesting i i would
have thought you might have said the
singularity
or perhaps the initial creation event
but
you seem to say the cmb is the worst
aspect of it
which is bad news for me because i study
the cmb
and its polarization now i want to ask
you
if you were gamov or somebody else
what would they say is the biggest
problem with the qssc
defect what would
you say the biggest problem with qssc
a critic someone who's criticizing it
you see uh what happens is that in the
qssc
the microwave background was not
predicted but is explained afterwards
whereas in the big bang if you remember
gamma's students they had written a
paper
saying that the relic radiation
should be around and this was a
prediction
so when something follows after the
prediction
you tend to believe it more than
something that has been explained after
it has been
observed right i would say
the quality wise
the defect is not there
it is quantity wise quality wise
one could say that people
could explain the
[Music]
microwave background in qssc using
thermalization of starlight and various
other
galaxy lights and that thermalization
process is a very
unusual one but it is
not possible i mean it is observed
in certain part of the galaxy
so we know that that kind of absorption
is there
so obama answered his main question
opponents of qss
what do the opponents of qss
point out as a defect of qss
well as i said they would say
that both accelerating universe and
microwave background those are
not explained by steady state causing
statistics
my answer is that it is explained that
it is given in
reputed papers would you only you should
go and read it
so i wouldn't accept that criticism
right yes there's the difference between
a prediction
and a retroaddiction and it's obviously
better to have
it's better to have a prediction
although many theories were predicted um
you know or rather i should say more
there have been oftentimes people have
retrodicted something like einstein and
the perihelion of mercury
uh but but they later turn out to then
make new predictions so
um but do you guys um i don't remember
if you predicted the acceleration you
you were trying to come up with an
expansion mechanism and that was this
creation field or dust
but um do you think that
do you think that hoyle who said once he
said and i quote this in my book in
losing the nobel prize i talk about
hoyle thought that cosmologists were
religious that they believed in the
bible too much
that the universe began uh with genesis
did you did he mean that seriously in
your opinion
that the cosmologist of the 60s believed
in the genesis or the biblical
creation story do you think
oil was serious when he said
that many cosmologists believed
in the genesis of bible
was he serious or was he joking
i think he was quite serious
and although he may have said it in a
kind of half-joking
fashion i i don't know whether you have
seen a
photograph of fred oil being presented
to the pope no there was an iau meeting
where this pope was around in italy so
they arranged this so why when he's
talking to the
to put the pope the pope is holding the
cross in his hand
it looks as if he's he's scared of this
and anti-god person a vampire
no i'll have to look up that picture
that would be very funny to me
willy powder took that photograph oh wow
wow very interesting um so
the next we're almost done with the
questions but i want to ask you about
some
alternative models that are
different than qssc such as for example
this year
uh sir roger penrose won the nobel prize
for his work on black holes as um as you
know
and he's been on my show very recently
too
as well as uh many others and but martin
um sorry uh going back to roger penrose
he has a model which also doesn't have
singularities in it
what is your impression of sir rogers
conformal
cyclic cosmology
well and you are referring to other
theories that means
not to do with steady state yes
secret call but not study
let me remind him when penrose was here
in pune
he at that time he was talking about his
model
which was conformal model and that
that did that also it was not quasi
steady state but that also explained it
was different from big bang i
i also remember that do you have any
opinion on those
not really because i i do know
some alternative cosmologies exist
which are not of the steady-state origin
or
quasi-steady state but i have not
studied them in
detail to see to what extent they have
succeeded
i i feel there should be more people
studying these things
yeah that brings me to one of my last
questions
is about why is it important to have
alternative models of the origin of the
universe
why is that important to have more than
one
we don't have more than one theory of
electromagnetism
why do you want to have more theory you
see
alternative model you go for
if you don't like what is existingly
existing at the moment so
there may be different reasons
for different people to opt to have up
for this mod these alternatives
i would suggest that
the reason
has been partly the fact that the big
bang has a singularity
singular origin which is a defect of a
physical theory and this second thing is
there are many places where
the observations are explained
by adding extra parameters without
realizing
so this uh also is
uh likely reason
for other cosmologists who are non
who are non big bang cosmology for them
to have chosen these
alternative routes
can i can i add just mine yes of course
i i i study mathematics yes
and i have been observing all these
people
talking about cosmology and different
theories
and i have come to the conclusion
that there is no theory which is
completely perfect
and can explain all the observations
if that is the case why not keep
three four different theories before
us and keep studying them and see
finally which one will fit best
why don't we learn from the history
like newton's laws i mean we have been
studying them in school for years and
they are so
perfect and so nice but even they
when they could not explain the
movements of mercury perfectly
people had kept that problem alive
and when einstein came with his theory
and when that theory explained this
better
it was supposed to be better it was an
addition to
newton's theory maybe in different
scales
different theories work more efficiently
why don't we keep our minds open
and consider different theories in case
yours is not perfect that's fine yes i
agree manjala i think
people in physics feel two things they
don't like
philosophy which i don't i don't
understand why
physicists don't like philosophy but
they also don't like
history they find it a distraction
they'd rather be doing something
so most of my colleagues would rather
just make more and more
uh make make more and more contributions
to kind of existing work i think
it takes a lot of courage whether or not
i agree i
i look at data and i look at models i
don't come up with new models but um but
i
agree with you mangela i think it is
incredibly important to have
much many many ideas and then uh
see which ones can be confronted with
data
and then the data that's my job and my
colleagues jobs with telescopes
and then we compare of course it's
always nice when there's a prediction as
giant was saying
but you're right people don't learn from
history like you say
and i mean it's just the extension of
newton's theory
by einstein is a very good example you
want to say something
no i i wanted to say that if you take
i want to give an example that jeffrey
burves
all through his life was trying to show
that there is periodicity in the
redshift distribution
of quasars see and
then he also talked about various other
aspects of non-cosmological relationship
now the situation since then
is that very recently four indians have
worked on a model of statistics
to do and do an analysis analysis of the
data
more critically and they had taken
a big sample like sloan
survey and so forth for red ships
and he showed uh they have shown
that there is a periodicity of
and mind you this has appeared in
astronomy and astrophysics
which is a ref refereed journal and
which is rather conservative
in approach so even in that
thing the referee accepted the paper
and the paper says that the ideas which
oil and i had proposed
in the makian gravitation theory
that it does seem to apply
to these samples so i think this
issue should be kept open rather than
say that that it doesn't exist or it is
not
right right um
before i turn to the end of the
questions i have some questions from
manjala
that you have studied uh my name is
mangala
yes and you studied uh your
mathematician and of course
uh you have been married for a long time
and you guys have daughters together
but you've published many many papers
and
in particular you worked on properties
of integers
etc and urdosh i wonder did you ever
how can how close were you to erdos in
terms of what is your urdosh number
my error number is two in fact i
had yes he used to visit i was working
in tifr
tata institute where giant was a
professor but
before i married giant i was a research
student there
yes and before i could complete my phd
work i
uh married giant and went off to
cambridge setting up the house having
kids
starting to cook and keep the house they
kept me very much busy and
but i took it took interest in
everything luckily when we came back to
mumbai
jain got a professorship in the ifr he
chose tifr as the best place to work
and where he was a professor in another
department
i could continue with my study in
mathematics again
so after looking after the kids and
doing the house work in my spare time i
started going to my old department
my supervisor had left uh i must go and
open the door and come back i'm sorry
okay
okay
i'll ask giant then my question for you
uh you wrote many books on science
fiction
and uh in particular what do you prefer
science fiction writing or writing
non-fiction books
okay what do you prefer writing science
fiction
or writing non-fiction
well i have enjoyed writing
science fiction novels
i have also enjoyed explaining
some of these astronomical events to
layman
both are both require different kind of
approach but
they are both uh i found absorbing
they are very they are very well
received they are very and i should tell
you
he's a bit shy that he has written
an autobiography he wrote it in marathi
in our local language and that won him
the national award of the
literature from delhi and he has got it
translated in english now he
translated it himself
and he has been writing very well ah
now now about my career again yes my my
career was looking after the house and
kids
jan's parents were also they moved in
with us i had to look after them also
and in my spare time i started working
in mathematics
my supervisor had left he had gone to
europe but
i started with the new research students
again
after six years they had joined and i
found i changed my field a little bit
from analytic geometry i shifted to
analytic number theory
and i managed to solve a problem and get
a phd
that was the advantage i had because
giant took a job in tifr
because if you know traveling in bombay
it is so difficult
that if i had to travel for one hour to
go to the place of work i
simply could not have done it i had
hardly two hours every day
and but my the other stuff was very
cooperative
they they used to have the lectures when
i had time to attend
that was nice oh wow that's very nice
and you've well
yeah now i am a teacher of mathematics
and i'm working for school children
i have supervised the textbooks in my
state
and they are received well oh wow
now some of your children your daughters
have become scientists as well
uh what but they didn't they didn't take
after either one of you there they went
into different fields of biology and
chemistry right
they are very good with basic maths in
our
house it has to be yes and the oldest
one she is a professor of
biochemistry in ucsf okay
she has her own lab and her students are
also progressing
the second one did computer science she
did phd from
carnegie mellon she is now working for
google
girija that is and none of them
changed their names after marriage as
normally indian women do they do
third one is leela and she decided
to combine both the fields she
works in computer science but she does
applications of computer science to
biology
ah very interesting but but they chose
their fields
really of course but basic knowledge of
mathematics yes they must have
they must know that and they probably
came here to san diego maybe
to visit when jar when giant was here i
remember
many times you guys or at least giant i
remember many times you were here and i
hope
you'll be able to come back someday
because we miss you and
and you're certainly a legend in the
field of cosmology
and i remember how happy jeff would be
whenever you'd come to visit
and um and even our our assistant
peggy mccoy she sends regards to you
as well because uh she she worked very
closely
you will visit pune sometime and visit
the institute that giant was the
director and founder of i would love to
i've never been to india at all but that
brings me to my final question
which is for both of you i want you each
to answer separately
what would advice would you give to your
younger self and i'm going to phrase it
the name of this podcast is called into
the impossible
it's based on sir arthur c clarke and he
said the only way to find out what's
possible
is to go beyond into the impossible
and i want to ask giant first and then
mangala i want to ask you too
what thing about life seemed very scary
when you were very young a 20 year old
person
what scared you but then you had courage
and you went
into the impossible so giant you first
you have a lot of courage advice to
these students would be
to be honest with you with what they
like
sometimes they are made to do research
in an area in which there is a bandwagon
effect
they have to do it otherwise but they
are not really convinced that is
correct so you should be convinced that
you are
along a worthwhile path
it is see and what about you
i think the scientists are
and should be the seekers of the truth
irrespective of all other things
and to find the truth yeah as jain says
you have to be brave you don't have to
follow the line unless you are convinced
but main thing is the truth stands above
all of us so
leave alone all the personal things and
try to get what is the
correct thing what is the best thing and
don't be afraid of the truth i don't
know whether you
read the story about fred when he was in
primary school
so the class miss the teacher
asked them to go and collect a certain
type of flower
and she claimed that each flower has
five petals cloven clover flower which
you always find in the grass
yeah so you
go bring it and you will see it so
they brought each uh class
and the whole class brought things like
that
now the one with jeff brown
played brought was that it showed
so he asked the teacher you said
there are five i can and believe there
can be four
if one is now
and the teacher got very annoyed with
this questioning
and she boxed his ear
he went home right away
he did not want to stay in the school
and then he
complained his mother
was in favor of him
when she heard all the details and then
uh it went on until the
headmaster said that friends can
because he didn't want to go into that
school again
so they said you can change the school
and they will arrange that
so this was an example
of fred not liking the conventional
wisdom
and reacting to authority something
unusual
yeah and he was showing evidence yeah he
he certainly had uh his is uh his
challenge to authority he was not one to
to go along with the geese the flock of
geese that i've heard you talk about
uh before anyway i thought i would only
get one
dr narlikar and i got two it's a bonus
prize
angela thank you so much gian thank you
so much
this is such a lovely treat for me it's
an honor to
to meet you both or to see you both i do
hope that you have a wonderful
new year healthy and happy and i do hope
that we meet a get meet someday
in person either in california or maybe
in pune that would be wonderful for me
too
that would be nice yes thank you thank
you guys good night thanks for going
into the impossible with me
good night guys our good